une main des pieds et une impression de
voler bienvenue à l'espace dédié au
lamentin bienvenue dans ce court de gaz
l'un des cours proposés dans ce stage
unique en son genre
aux états non
un stage intensif sur deux semaines où
le caf côtoie le dancehall et l'afrobeat
ça commence à 6 heures du matin et finit
à 22h à la baguette il ya robert regina
à la fois professeur et organisateurs
alors ce n'est vraiment pas facile
financièrement puisque bon si vous posez
la question
le stage dépend entièrement de mon
salaire d'abord puisqu'il n'y a pas de
subvention n'y a rien donc ce stage
s'autofinance à la fin donc ça avec les
entrées au final qu'on arrive à se
rembourser d'abord et ensuite à essayer
de rémunérer enfin de donner un
défraiement plutôt en radiant aux
professions qui les accompagne pas de
niveau minimum requis tout le monde peut
venir pour les stagiaires c'est surtout
l'occasion de tester des choses
nouvelles
je faisais de la gym qui fait trois ans
que j'y joue j'ai arrêté et je me suis
dit pourquoi pas là d'un comics un stage
de danse ça me permet de faire autre
dans ce que je peux chez moi à l'année
dans mon école
cette année les grandes vedettes sont
surtout les cours de dance hall et
d'afrobeat on peut entrer dans le stage
à tout moment et comme le dit le
professeur
c'est
[Musique]